boa noite meu nome amanda eu sou jovem
eu sou mulher e eu sou ativista e eu sou
ativista porque eu trabalho todo dia e
irá lutar por um mundo mais justo e
igualitário é por isso agora todos os
dias ela tá junto com pessoas que
acreditam que o nosso trabalho pode
transformar a vida de outras pessoas
quando eu estava na escola
eu lembro de uma aula de geografia eu
gostava muito de ver os mapas e eu olhei
para o mapa da da áfrica e perguntei
professor porque é que os quadros na
divisão entre os países eram todos em
linha reta e fiquei com aquela
inquietação sempre um professor tem
muito inquieta pra entender o que aquilo
significava
e ao longo da minha trajetória foi
entender quais eram os efeitos da
colonização é das pessoas para as
comunidades e como elas atingem as
pessoas até hoje é por causa da
inquietação eu fui fazer relações
internacionais alguma relação com os
mapas com a geografia me levou para o
curso de r eu sou do interior de são
paulo já era clara e mudei para são
paulo
na cidade grande a grande metrópole pra
entender um pouco melhor um pouco mais
de como eu
através da implantação desse novo no
estômago que eu tinha eu podia
transformar a realidade a minha
realidade ea realidade de outras pessoas
no brasil e no mundo é
durante a faculdade foi o de conhecer as
pessoas que também tinham esse
sentimento foi na faculdade que eu pude
compartilhar essa vontade de causar
transformação no no planeta
e quando falo isso parece que é um sonho
muito grande né parece estar muito longe
mas foi através de compartilhando essa
história compartilhando essa vontade que
eu conheci essas pessoas maravilhosas
que acompanharam comigo a minha
trajetória e um pouquinho do que eu vou
compartilhar com vocês aqui hoje é em
2012 aconteceu a rio + 20 a conferência
de desenvolvimento sustentável da onu
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar mas
aconteceu aqui no rio de janeiro e como
fazer relações internacionais onde falou
'vamos lá vão participar
vamos falar com os tomadores de decisão
sei lá vai que a gente senta com o
presidente ele pode falar quais são os
nossos anseios e os nossos motivos de
mudança porque a gente acha que os
jovens são importantes e relevantes para
a transformação sócio ambiental e
chegando lá nada disso aconteceu
a gente não tinha credencial né o cartão
que você precisa plantar uma conferência
da onu tem milhares de seguranças lá e
tudo é muito difícil de acontecer mas
também teve que organizar um evento em
menos de 24 horas
e isso gerou muita resiliência é muito
aprendizado e e nesse espaço com essas
pessoas que acreditavam que participar
daquilo mesmo com aquelas profissões era
relevante surgiu a vontade de fazer
alguma coisa com aquilo e aumentar a
participação da juventude brasileira
nesses espaços de tomada de decisão
internacional
então depois da rio +20 a gente voltou
para são paulo e falou vamos fazer
alguma coisa com isso como que a gente
pode aumentar então a participação
desses jovens nas conferências e aí
surgiu a idéia de criar uma organização
porque não né
parecia tão simples parecer tão fácil
mas porque a gente compartilhava as
mesmas idéias e os mesmos anseios
a gente começou a organização do zero
é muito
a fio muita coisa aconteceu
fazem idéia de por que não ir para uma
próxima conferência em 2013 foi
acontecer a conferência de mudanças
climáticas a cop 19
esta conferência acontece todos os anos
e ela fala de vários problemas das
mudanças climáticas você já deve ter
ouvido falar do acordo de paris foi
assinado na copa 21 em paris e a gente
tinha essa vontade de compartilhar
aquilo que a gente tinha aprendido então
através das suas frustrações e desses
desafios que a gente enfrentou
participando da rio +20 como a gente
podia compartilhar isso com outros
jovens que eu acredito realmente que se
a gente adquirir um conhecimento
a gente já sabe como fazer aqui o né
como fazer as coisas a gente tem que
compartilhar a gente provocar uma
transformação ainda maior
a gente montou uma formação né
um atacante era um preze no caso que a
gente contava passo a passo de como você
podia a participar de uma conferência
internacional e chegou o grande dia de
dar essa informação eu tinha eu a laura
e raquel é mais duas duas amigas que
estavam nesse processo também estava
muito animada e a ser a primeira
atividade que a gente vai fazer como
parte de uma organização compartilhar
todo esse conhecimento que tinha
adquirido
chegou o grande dia da formação tinham
três pessoas e foi frustrante mas a
gente nem imaginava que esse seria um
dos primeiros desafios que a gente até
como organização não é como ir no
cartório como tem que captar recursos
para a organização se manter as coisas
que hoje são parte do meu dia a dia mas
que na época foram vários desafios que
foram sendo enfrentados mas que tinha
muitas pessoas que também acreditavam
que esse desafio
podia causar impacto na vida de mais
pessoas e
depois dessa formação
e de todos esses desafios que a gente
enfrentou como a organização possa
contar pra vocês hoje que esse sonho e
foi compartilhado com outras pessoas com
amigas minhas durante a faculdade
ele já atingiu mais de 90 mil pessoas no
brasil e no mundo
a gente já está e nas cinco regiões do
brasil que era a principal universidade
que a gente queria atingir quando a
gente sonhou em uma organização que
pudesse conversar com outros jovens
e naquela naquele sonho que a gente
tinha imaginado como chegar os cinco
cantos do brasil representando o brasil
tão grande né
ali na minha como gostava muito de ver
mapa falei nossa amazônia que distante e
chegar nesses jovens que têm uma
realidade muito diferente mas ao mesmo
tempo muito parecida com a minha é uma
satisfação assim imensa
eu mesmo já tem mais de 40 formações com
aquela formação frustrada que só foram
três pessoas
conseguimos superar e já de informações
para jovens do brasil inteiro e nessas
informações a gente fala sobre as
questões das mudanças climáticas por
exemplo que eu contei para vocês aqui um
pouquinho dessa conferência
mas fala sobre os problemas da
biodiversidade questões de gênero o
desenvolvimento sustentável ads que
talvez vocês já estejam familiarizados
com as questões dos problemas do
desenvolvimento urbano e sempre
aplicando essas formações com os jovens
e aí vira e mexe pergunta para mim assim
manda porque os jovens a começar a eu
sou jovem ainda e quando em 2012 a gente
viu essa conferência que tinha o quiz e
nos jovens representando o brasil a
juventude brasileira oi tem uma
oportunidade hoje um quarto da população
brasileira são jovens no mundo
historicamente mas tem o maior número da
população brasileira de jovens são da
população mundial são jovens na história
são quase dois milhões de jovens do
mundo e jovens
eles são a população que eu acredito c
uma das mais impactadas seja
positivamente ou seja negativamente por
ações humanas né porque pelo que a gente
está fazendo
ou seja dependendo o meio ambiente seja
falei fazendo políticas públicas que não
condizem com a realidade ou consumindo
muito então o jovem quando ele é
impactado negativamente o que eu vejo eu
acredito aqui
ou ele pode se desestruturar e se
desestabilizar mas por esses anos pra
esses últimos cinco anos de jornada
o que eu vejo é um poder enorme de
transformação é um sentimento que nasce
dentro dessas pessoas como nasceu em mim
essa inquietação para fazer alguma coisa
diferente e para mudar a nossa realidade
e como que a gente muda a nossa
realidade hoje né
as conferências internacionais por eu
ter feito relações internacionais e por
achar que os tomadores de decisão que
estão no mundo eles iriam tomar as
decisões por nós
ela sim são uma ferramenta hoje que a
gente utiliza mas as nossas principais
atividades são as atividades locais que
é onde a gente consegue ver a
transformação que a gente pode fazer em
nós mesmos e na nossa comunidade através
desse tipo de ações seja através das
formações ou seja através do de ativismo
é alguma manifestação que a gente faz
com outras pessoas a gente pode gerar um
poder maior de consciência ea
conscientizando outras pessoas outros
jovens ou não os jovens também sobre os
problemas que a gente está enfrentando e
ao longo dessa jornada né eu aprendi
muitas coisas por exemplo os efeitos do
desmatamento como eles afetam hoje a
nossa realidade como as emissões de
gases de efeito estufa coisas muito
complicadas
elas por devido ao desmatamento elas
afetam a nossa realidade mas não só no
brasil no mundo todo é foi ao longo
dessa experiência também que me
conscientizei sobre o consumo de carne
que a gente diz mata até
nas matas florestas hoje ainda para
consumir e demais pastas de consumir
mais carne como nós consumo ele está
sendo desviado ea gente consome mais
plástico a gente consome coisas que a
gente não consumir antes e como isso
afeta inevitavelmente o nosso planeta e
através dessas ações
a gente pode usar uma linguagem mais
divertida
a gente pode atingir jovens e falar com
eles de igual para igual pra que a gente
possa transformar a nossa realidade
então são essas ações hoje que eu
trabalho e são essas ações que elas
proporcionam diversas mudanças na
realidade é de muitas pessoas
eu queria contar pra vocês uma história
é de que aconteceu com um amigo ano
passado é o ano passado a partir de um
encontro de mais de 100 pessoas eram 100
jovens do brasil inteiro e
principalmente jovens de comunidades
indígenas e tradicionais na região do
tapajós o tapajós fica no pará é essa é
no bairro tapajós na região de alter do
chão onde queriam construir é os
vereadores a câmera a câmara queria
construir ia passar uma o projeto de lei
para construir prédios na praia
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar nessa
região mas é paradisíaca
são praias de rios são rios imensos você
nem vê o outro lado do rio e construir
um prédio lá seria muito incoerente
assim com a realidade a natureza lhe as
comunidades e vem da própria pesca e
você irá alterar todo aquele ambiente
por meio da ação conjunta da sociedade
civil e ativistas
a comunidade local advogados
outros vereadores que estavam do nosso
lado né a gente e aí o que a gente
construiu esse bando
o tapajós livre dos prédios e todas
essas diferentes ações elas puderam
proporcionar o fretamento dessa desse
projeto de lei pois teve um sucesso
quando a gente compartilhou é o nossos
anseios do nosso medo daquela
transformação naquele local e o que eu
queria contar que eu queria compartilhar
aqui com vocês hoje é que uma ideia um
sentimento um sonho se ele vive sozinho
se ele é fica na apenas no nível
individual a chance de ele quebrar uma
barreira a chance de ele se espalhar
pelo mundo é muito pequena e pela minha
experiência o sonho ou uma ideia quando
compartilhado ele reverbera nas outras
pessoas ele faz sentido para outras
pessoas e ele tem um enorme poder de
transformação
eis brigada
[Aplausos]